le calme aussi le recueillement et
surtout pas de débordements tels étaient
les mots d'ordre des jeunes gens qui
avaient choisi de défiler aujourd'hui en
signe de deuil après la mort du jeune
malik oussékine environ 3000 personnes
cet après midi dans les rues de paris un
cortège l'on parlait aussi beaucoup bien
sûr du retrait du projet de loi
le reportage de françois cornet et
olivier lerner et vernier défilé de la
sorbonne à la bastille pour malik
oussékine trente mille étudiants et
lycéens parfaitement silencieux
parfaitement digne aucun cri
aucun slogan pas la moindre banderole
les graffitis sur les murs parlent d'eux
mêmes
dorénavant
le gouvernement devra discuter avec nous
et c'est pour cela que c'est une
victoire
néanmoins ça a coûté très cher je pense
est trop chère à vis d'un homme c'est
beaucoup trop pour un projet de loi pour
un peu d'argent créé un peu de papier je
pense on a eu une autre satisfaction du
côté du projet devaquet mais pour ce qui
est de nos copains qui sont morts enfin
notre copain qui mord et les autres qui
sont eux qui ont été blessés
on continue à manifester de toute façon
des dizaines de masse anonyme ont déposé
des couronnes de fleurs rue monsieur le
prince
là même où malik est tombé regroupés
derrière une simple couronne de roses
blanches
le cortège est passé ensuite devant
l'hôpital cochin pour rejoindre enfin la
place de la bastille aucun incident
n'est venu troubler la manifestation un
simple refrain a été entendu au moment
de la dispersion de vaquer on l'a eu
monory on leur a